l'an passé nous avons on adore arnaud
ducret et à la couleur
[Applaudissements]
je suis juste pour dire sur et des 8 la
chaîne a mis son nom sur mon facebook
que je vais passer à 18h50
j'arrive la bande divin en bas et gary
ce qu'elles auraient dit les normands
10e
je suis là mais dans les loges j'avais
18 ans j'ai 22ans chronicles
interminable pourquoi tes parents 2 0 je
peux moi mais je rends pas comme ça chez
les gens que tu rates comme ça il est
fan absolu de michael jackson ducret pef
aucun des deux ne crée j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jérôme et en direct sur d8
c'est la première fois je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'on va faire un cache cache
j'ai posé par vidal je me suis intégré
dans les gammes n' ya qu' il y a deux
thés bing il y un thème le premier thème
c'est j'ai envie de vous dire le câlin
le bien-être ya une bonne nouvelle dans
la un hall a2 ou une mauvaise nouvelle
dans la ou à deux mais mon cas moi je le
prends
[Applaudissements]
cette fois vous allez tourner votre
langue dans la bouche d'eric qui notre
chauffeur de salle qu'on aime ouais
rick s'il vous plaît tant mieux
maintenant c'est la tarte soit elle et à
manger soit elle et comment mes lunettes
s'il te plaît chine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]